- The last text message
my mom sent to me was
"Did Beyonce have her babies yet?"
I said "I don't know." and she said
"You work at Buzzfeed,
for the love of God."
(playful music)
- Costco had the most
beautiful hanging plants
so I had to get two, smiley face.
- Me and my mom are on a diet together,
so the last thing she texted me is,
"I am star-ving,
I begged dad to get me a
Whopper from Burger King
but he didn't, he's such an asshole."
- The last thing that my mom texted me
is a kiss-face emoji, and a heart emoji.
- The last text my mom sent me is
"Stay on our health insurance."
- The last thing my mom
texted me is that my parents
got approved to adopt a dog named Hank!
- The last thing my mom texted me was
"I'm going to fire emoji, devil emoji."
So I'm going to hell.
- My mom sent me a picture of her
and asked if her concealer was too light.
- "Good morning, are you up yet?"
- I asked her if she
would come to New York,
and she was like "You
want me to visit you?"
and she was excited, and then I said
"No, I want you to...
I want you to dog-sit."
but she didn't respond
to that, so (laughs)
I feel a little guilty.
- The last thing my mom texted me
was a picture of damage that my dad caused
trying to DIY a dishwasher installation.
And I said "Rough times."
- Okay, so my mom recently texted me
the entire lyrics to the
songs Father & Daughter
by Paul Simon, literally the entire song.
There it is, see it?
Still going.
- So the last text
message I got from my mom
was actually a smiley face,
because she was thanking me on
being the biggest gift that she has,
and because I took her out for dinner
for Guatemalan Mothers
Day, which is May 10th.
- "Timmy was in the well again."
My families one dog constantly escapes,
and we always joke that
he's going to rescue Timmy
from the well, so my dog got out again.
(laughs) That's it.
- [Voicemail] Hey Christian, yeah,
I figured since you're busy at work
you probably wouldn't answer the phone,
but I'm so thrilled about that article,
so proud of you, very
proud, love you, bye!
- Happy Mothers Day mom!
- I love you mom!
- Happy Mothers Day mom.
- Happy Mothers Day mom!
(cheerful music)